[Music]
you will emerge today's episode being a
better you in life we must each deal
with the hand we are dealt performing
our assigned role to the best of our
capacities but after total atomic
annihilation you may find the hand you
were dealt has been reshuffled yes gone
are the simple days of yesteryear now
the common workmen must also be a covert
operative the farmer a master of the
martial arts the ice-cream man a nuclear
physicist how will you make sense of it
all simple turn to your official
vault-tec training materials with these
powerful tools in hand you'll learn to
make the most of your natural abilities
and better understand what makes you
special use them to be the best you you
can be or someone even better your
survival depends on it with your future
secure share your newfound knowledge
with others a great benefit
[Music]
but remember there's power in diversity
[Music]
sometimes who we are isn't a choice at
all
in fact at a particular point in your
young life you may notice that your body
has begun going through certain
unfamiliar changes no it's not puberty
its mutation thanks to our old pal
radiation your DNA has become more
interesting see here you've now gained
the unique abilities of a marsupial in
exchange for a mild neurological
impairment now you've learned how to be
a better you
you are completely prepared to achieve
your full potential in the role of your
choosing as a hand-picked resident of
vault 76 it is your duty to carefully
review your vault-tec provided films
yearly to fully prepare for the day when
will emerge
[Music]
play the beta first on Xbox one
[Music]